this is a production of Cornell
University thanks everyone is the volume
okay okay
so while we were waiting here I was
talking with Bob and Mike and the
question came up about for a lot of us
how many of the decisions that we've
made previous in our lives could have
ended us ended us up being in prison as
opposed to being yeah right so that's
which we can take a vote here I think
it's important to recognize in the
context of the prison education program
that although some of the guys in prison
have done some really bad things others
are in there for less offensive offenses
drug related stuff and things like that
and a lot of them are very very
interesting people and I hope that I
will give you some perspective on that I
want to start off by thanking Adrienne
because she encouraged me to give this
seminar today I think I was pretty
reluctant at the beginning and after all
I think as classes giving you some a
little bit of flavor the path that I
followed through Cornell in academics
has been no two or three standard
deviations from the mean
whatever the mean is for academics but
the path I follow this to a large extent
guided me and shaped my interests and
passion about teaching and I'd like to
give you some perspective on that and
teaching in the prison is just just one
aspect of that but as I was planning the
seminar today a number of my colleagues
suggested that I should give some
background about where my passion for
teaching came from so I'm gonna start
off with a brief history of time and
I'll do this for several reasons first
and probably most importantly as I said
there's some logic to the fact that the
things that I've done have led me to my
desire to be a teacher and to be
involved in the prison education program
well there's also a lot of you who are
relatively new to Cornell who maybe only
know me as a teacher that you've had in
class or
spawned someone that you spoken to about
measuring fluorescence I don't really
know a whole lot about about me and a
lab it I think I have a pretty
interesting background it's certainly
bizarre and so I'll give you some
history on that and hopefully it'll
permit us to have a little bit of fun
primarily at my expense so if we're
gonna have a brief history of time we
really need to start at the beginning
and it appears looking back over my
history that there was some link between
me and Cornell that started very early
my dad and his brother both went to
Cornell as undergraduates my dad never
finished he joined the army but my my
uncle finished and went on to become a
physician apparently I had some
connection to but what it really is I
can't remember so here's a picture of me
and my two younger siblings I was six at
the time and I have my homemade Cornell
sweatshirt with the number 16 I have no
idea what the basis of this was but
clearly it pointed my direction toward
Cornell from a very early age now one of
the things that some of the students in
here in my plant physiology class know
that one of the things I complain about
a lot not a lot but some is that the
pictures that students give to Cornell
at the time that they apply that become
attached to their student records and
that we see as faculty when we see our
class lists often look nothing like the
students that they look like now and so
one of the students in my plant
physiology class challenged me to make
the same assessment for myself so here I
am in 1969 when I graduated from high
school and Here I am a mere two years
later as a chemistry major at the
University of Washington and clearly
this looks like it could be a mug shot
for some drug-related offense it's
actually a passport picture
oh yeah right in the first in the time
that it took me to get my bachelor's
degree University of Washington I
actually did have two mugshots
taken of me the first very interesting
circumstances I was actually held as a
suspect by the FBI for blowing up the
ROTC building at the University of
Washington in the fall of 1970
fortunately I had a really good alibi
and was not held for that in the second
instance I actually spent a night in
jail
in the small town of Madison O
Washington for riding my bike on a
four-lane highway in order to avoid 30
miles of really crappy roads that alibi
didn't work so well for me so file there
are endeavors at University of
Washington actually turned out a little
bit better I started working in lab at
the beginning of my junior year I spent
so much time in the lab it took me five
and a half years to get my bachelor's
degree but one of the outcomes of this
was that by the time I finished my
degree I had actually published three
papers one of these papers an
interesting one had to do with the
silicate budget for the world's ocean I
spent the summer working on a Canadian
icebreaker up in the Arctic this is what
it looked like in the ocean as we were
taking samples working around ice floes
but the idea was to really try to put
together a picture of the of the
silicate budgets for the world's oceans
and it it came there is a really
interesting outcome that came from this
that was pretty pretty popular back then
the study permitted us to do to
basically build a model of how nutrients
moves through the world's oceans and
back-calculate to the time that the
bering sea land bridge disappeared and
the number that we calculated from our
budgets agreed very well with the other
geological data so it was a pretty
popular paper so shortly after this
paper was published in limnology and
oceanography I was accepted into a ph.d
program at the University of Washington
and chemical oceanography I was working
in the same lab that I'd worked in the
previous three years because I'd been an
undergraduate in the program I'd already
taken all the courses
at the beginning of my first year I
decided I would take my qualifying exams
qualifying exams back then were a little
more challenging to day exam eight hours
each day for essay questions total one
on chemistry one on physics when I'm
biology and one on geology the geology
question asked about the effects of
silicate input by the four major Russian
rivers into the Arctic Ocean and its
effect on the world silicate budget the
professor that wrote the question had
clearly seen my paper but had no idea
that I was one of the authors of the
papers more importantly when he graded
the paper he failed me on my question
and refused to regrade so at the end of
that semester I left the University of
Washington pretty disgusted with what
was going on and I took a job as a
technician at Brookhaven National
Laboratory in oceanographic Sciences
down on Long Island and my fiancee a
Verena
also got offered a job there so it was
really easy for us to pick up and move
there and it was a very very good choice
on my part it was very successful time
by the time I started thinking about
graduate school five years later I had
my name on 19 more papers I was starting
to be invited to speak at national
conferences but the Department of Energy
that ran the National Labs and their
infinite wisdom would not allow people
without a PhD to present work that was
done at a national lab at any meetings
so the decision for me to go and get a
PhD was a relatively easy one so to make
this decision I had to figure out where
I wanted to go and who I wanted to work
with and I was fortunate that the year
that I started thinking about this the
topic for the annual Brookhaven
symposium on biology was marine
photosynthesis so we brought in world's
experts on photosynthesis to talk at
this meeting and one night at the
Brookhaven lounge and if you don't
haven't been to Brookhaven Brookhaven in
fact does have its own bar on the site
because it's so far
isolated from everything they had to do
that to attract people to come there so
one night at this bar a group of these
colleagues decided to decide my fate in
photosynthesis who I should go work for
for my degrees and interestingly the
result was almost unanimous there were
really only two people that I should
think about working with or in Butler
who is it University of California in
San Diego and rod Clayton who was here
at Cornell the decision was that I
should choose one of these labs to get
my PhD and the other lab to do my
postdoc in the decision to come to
Cornell for my PhD was pretty easy
because every and I could afford to live
in Ithaca on a graduate student stipend
and we probably couldn't do that very
well in San Diego as it turns out
neither one of these decisions would
have been very good Butler is all
already and relatively poor health and
he died about eighteen months later
Clayton's health was very good but his
wife BJ who had been his technician for
decades died right when I arrived at
Cornell from cancer and Clayton's
response was drugs particularly cocaine
in the three years that it took me to
complete my PhD I never actually
discussed my PhD research with Clayton
when I first came to Cornell first day I
entered the plant biology building I ran
into an interesting guy I ran into a guy
who introduced himself as Neil Campbell
now at that time Neil was an assistant
professor here at Cornell in plant
biology who was was just ready to leave
he's leaving Cornell pre tenured to move
to a faculty position at UC Riverside so
as many of you know Campbell is famous
for his introductory biology series of
books Campbell biology textbooks the
best-selling introductory biology
textbooks in the world
but at Cornell at that time he was
really known he had published these
books yet but he was known as a
fantastic teacher and our brief meeting
outside the front door of plant biology
was probably the most influential one of
my life
I told Neal that I was really interested
in teaching as an undergraduate I'd been
a teaching assistant in classes at
University of Washington
when I was at Brookhaven I taught three
years at SUNY Stony Brook and he was
really happy to hear about this but he
warned me do not tell anyone else in the
department about your interest in
teaching that research is really what's
all that matters at Cornell and that if
you tell people about your interest in
teaching you'll be treated as a second
class class graduate student I never
really knew why Neal left Cornell but
his advice to me certainly gives a clue
I managed to suppress my interest in
teaching for more than ten years I'm
really happy to say that when I look
around at my peers and their students
now that this perspective seems to have
changed that students that are
interested in teaching really get the
chance to do that but I will also say
that when you consider the importance of
teaching versus research when it comes
to tenure and advancement for faculty
the position of the university has not
changed in the last 40 years okay so I
told you about my previous qualifying
exam at University of Washington so I
also have to tell you about my
qualifying exam here my a exam here at
Cornell so I had four faculty members on
my committee rod Clayton representing
biophysics Andre Hagen door for
representing plant biology dick McCarty
representing biochemistry and Andy
Albrecht representing physical chemistry
a pretty intimidating group three
members of the National Academy and I'll
admit when I went into my exam I was
pretty nervous I took turns asking me
questions Clayton went first and he
really worked me over he in fact was the
most cogent I ever saw him in the three
years I was a student at Cornell when he
was done he left the room went out and
smoked a joint came back
and giggled through the whole rest of
the exam yeag and orphaned McCarty were
next and they were a bit kinder to me
they asked some pretty reasonable
questions it was fun and when auntie
Albrecht was asking me questions at the
end he asked me to derive the spin
Hamiltonian for an electron in a
hydrogen anion an interesting question
so interesting that during the question
on draygon Dorf was sound alseep had tip
back sawing logs completely gone in the
end they decided to pass me okay so um
as all of you are aware who have been
here for a while
Cornell has influences it changes us in
many ways so this is a picture of me and
every nough the spring before I started
graduate school at Cornell we were
camping on the North Shore of Kauai
three brief years later this is a
picture of me and every nough in our
backyard just before I was finishing up
my degree isn't it amazing what Cornell
does to people so at the time I was
finishing up Cornell had forced Clayton
to resign and they had started a search
for a replacement
I had already accepted a postdoc in
biophysics at the University of Chicago
but a number of faculty colleagues at
Cornell encouraged me to apply for the
position here thinking I had no chance
whatsoever
I applied anyway interestingly I made
the shortlist and my PhD defense seminar
was also my job seminar and after the
top the obvious top candidate for the
position turned Cornell down they
offered the position to me something I
really wonder whether they look back and
feel good about or whether they regret
okay so because I had accepted a postdoc
that you versus Chicago
Cornell decided they let me go they let
me put back my start date at Cornell for
a year and and do one year of postdoc so
I spent actually just ten months at
Chicago and these were scientifically
the most productive time in my career
the work that I completed over those 10
months resulted in 11 publications
including one in science and one in PNAS
of course it took us four years to get
those papers out and written but it was
worth it in the long run and I'm not how
do I say this right I don't say these
things because I'm trying to brag I'm
saying these things because many of you
only know me as a teacher and that as a
researcher I was a very successful
researcher and you'll see what happened
in just a second
so upon returning to Cornell I was
really fortunate to get a great group of
undergraduates graduate students and
postdocs to work in my lab and get the
funding to support them all this is a
picture of my plant biology lab group in
a photo synthesis meeting in Woods Hole
in 1992 just before I receive tenure at
the time I also had three PhD students
in chemistry I have to admit I really
loved having a big lab the interaction
between the students from disciplines
physics chemistry and biology was
outstanding it was just so much fun to
be with them it seemed like everything
was going so well about a month after I
was granted tenure my wife every nough
died from a brain hemorrhage she was
really the glue that held our lab
together she and I had worked together
in the lab since we were undergraduates
for almost 20 years and without her I
really just didn't have the desire or
the ability to run a big lab
I tell you this for two reasons the
first is this very strange parallel
between me and Rod Clayton for both of
us our wives had been our technicians
for a long time and really played a huge
role in making our labs work neither one
of us could really run a lab after our
wives passed away as I said clades
response was to turn to drugs for me I
chose a different drug
I chose teaching as my grad students and
postdocs finished up their programs I
started looking for new teaching
opportunities I taught a number of
classes of Cornell but they were mostly
8 or 10 students taking high level
photosynthesis and elbow physiology
classes about two years after after my
legs labs started getting smaller
a spot opened up in bio G 101 this is
our big 800 student introductory biology
course for freshman biology majors and
pre-meds the first four years I
co-taught the course with various people
Carl Hopkins David Robert Shaw Charley
Wolcott and Bob Turgeon before teaching
it for two years on my own during that
time I spent a lot of effort looking at
the cognitive science literature and the
science education literature trying to
understand what people thought were the
most effective ways to go about teaching
and learning I introduced the use of
clickers and active learning into our
large biology classrooms in 2005 I was
named a National Academies HHMI Teaching
Fellow and was also honored as a member
of Neil Campbell's initial group of
biology leadership Campbell biology
leadership group a group of faculty who
were involved in teaching introductory
biology around the country that same
year I was also banned from teaching
biology at Cornell by a Dean who could
not see beyond a small number of
students who didn't like the way I was
teaching because it was different
as you might be surprised knowing me I
was slightly discouraged by this
development and I took a year leave of
absence from Cornell to work for Pearson
Education that's the organization that
publishes Campbell's textbook during
this out year I oversaw the development
of the bio flick series which is 12 sort
of CSI level animations really high
level animations that looked at the
dynamics of fundamental processes in
biology that our introductory biology
students typically have difficulty with
things like photosynthetic and
respiratory electron transport or how
does water move up through the xylem in
the in a plant I also helped with the
development of mastering biology which
was an online Socratic quizzing platform
and wrote the tutorials that went along
with the bio flix animations these two
resources were credited with the 11%
increase of the sales of the eighth
edition of Campbell biology over the
previous edition unfortunately my
contract with Pearson Education did not
include royalties associated with
increase in sales otherwise Cornell
probably would never have seen me again
so my interest in teaching took a very
significant turn in 2009 when our own
Bob Turgeon approached me about
co-teaching a class in Auburn Auburn
Correctional Facility along with him and
then a plant biology graduate student
named Sarah Davidson who most of you
know this was before C pepp was actually
an official organization and Bob and
Sarah had taught a similar introductory
biology class at Auburn in the previous
year I guess they thought that I would
be an easy mark and how right they were
it was an eye-opening experience for me
in many ways and showed me that I really
didn't know as much about teaching as I
thought I did
so I think a little history about prison
education and the founding of CPAP is
really appropriate here it turns out
that one of the places were the emphasis
on rehabilitation as a part of
incarceration started an Auburn
Correctional Facility in the mid 1800s
the basic idea was to prepare
individuals for reintegration into
society through work through education
and through religious studies this basic
principle held true for almost a century
until the mid 1970s when the war on
drugs and the concept of being tough on
crime sort of took over as a result
there were two major changes in prisons
and prisoners in the United States the
first was that the number of prisons and
prisoners exploded in the early 1980s
and continued through the early 2000s a
very large part of this increase in the
number of prisoners was due to
individuals were convicted of minor drug
crimes as opposed to violent crimes and
the people convicted of these were
dominated by racial minorities at the
same time the u.s. became the world
leader in incarcerating its own citizens
we had more people in jail than any
other country on earth even when you
look at it as a fraction of the
population another consequence of this
get tough on crime perspective was that
in 1994 the US Congress declared that
incarcerated individuals were no longer
eligible to receive federal education
support from Pell grants every state
that supplied similar sorts of support
for prison education followed suit and
the result is that within just two years
the number of prison education programs
dropped from several hundred to just a
handful
into this void a number of people
stepped as individuals trying to change
things two of these people were here at
Cornell Pete Weatherby and Paul Sawyer
they were and still are professors in
the English department and for a number
of years they volunteered teaching
courses at Auburn Correctional Facility
and became basically beloved there for
the work that they did in 1999 Pete and
Paul did something that really changed
the way things work here at Cornell for
prison education they convinced the
School of Continuing Education to offer
the classes that that were taught in
prison is Cornell credit-bearing classes
and to waive the tuition for these
students
this agreement remains in effect to this
day and is fundamental to the way to the
success of our prison education program
so Auburn was the first prison built in
New York State in 1918 16 and as I
mentioned before it was the place where
this idea of rehabilitative
incarceration began but by the time Pete
and Paul got involved in teaching in
prison in the 1990s things were pretty
different this intimidating facade gives
little clue about the bleakness inside
this prison
if you go to the prison one of the
things you'll see is one of these New
York State signs that tells you that the
first electrocution of a prisoner in the
United States occurred in Auburn and in
fact if you until a few years ago when
you entered a burn right in the main
entryway hanging on the wall was a part
of that electric chair and across the
street in the local bar was the rest of
the electric chair things had changed a
lot I want to read you a few lines from
an essay that Pete Weatherby wrote about
prison education I think there's about
2005 when he wrote this think that this
really brings this idea of what's going
on into focus there was a time when
education was a part of the basic
correctional and rehabilitative mission
of the prison system as recently as the
1990s a great majority of state
corrections systems offered college
level programs that enabled inmates to
earn two and four-year degrees usually
through cooperation with local community
colleges every state could cite studies
and statistics demonstrating that
providing education in prison had a
direct and significant effect on
recidivism ensuring that men who had
served their time had a better chance to
avoid further crime and to remain free
by expanding their social horizons and
making them more employable as I said in
1994 this changed a lot continuing with
some of Pete's writing the concept of
imprisonment that had served as the
intellectual cornerstone of corrections
policy for nearly a century
the concept of rehabilitation was
publicly and politically discredited the
country moved from a society that
justified putting people in prison on
the basis of the belief that their
incarceration would somehow facilitate
their productive re-entry into society
into the free world and it changed this
to one where imprisonment was merely to
separate criminal offenders from the
rest of society to disable them in other
words the concept of rehabilitation had
really been lost from our prison
vocabulary in 2005 another cornell face
showed up in our prisons mary
katzenstein who's a professor in the
government department she had become
interested in the politics of
incarceration and joined Pete and Paul
in teaching classes at Auburn and in
2010 Mary was successful in getting
grant support from the Sun sunshine lady
foundation this is an organization
founded by Doris Buffett Warren
Buffett's sister had lots of money and
with this funding the Cornell prison
education program was officially born we
hired our first executive director Jim
Schecter a fantastic guy Jim immediately
negotiated an agreement between Cornell
and Hyuga Community College in Auburn
so that Cornell credits that our CPAP
students earn could be transferred to
Kega so that they could earn an
associate's degree in the liberal arts
Cornell did not want to give degrees to
incarcerated individuals what the excuse
that they used was that there's a
residence requirement at Cornell if
you're not living on campus for a
certain amount of time you can't get a
Cornell degree but now because of this
agreement with Keegan Community College
we can at least get them degree in
associate's degree in liberal arts so we
had our first graduation ceremony in the
summer of 2012 that again sitting there
in the middle is our own Bob Turgeon who
had been was the faculty director of the
Cornell prison education program
standing besides doors Buffett the
sunshine lady and president Larson who's
from Cuba Community College and our
first fourteen graduates of the C prep
program I honestly have to tell you that
it's really difficult to explain or
Express the emotions that were in
uniformly felt during this graduation it
was one of those events that just
changes the perspectives on life okay so
in 2013 Jim Schechter decided to change
jobs to move move into continuing
education here at Cornell and we hired
dr. Rob Scott as our new executive
director and I think it's fair to say
that Rob is largely responsible for the
absolute explosion in the success of the
prison education program over the last
five years we've expanded from teaching
in one prison to four now including
Hyuga Correctional Facility which is a
medium-security facility in Moravia Five
Points which is a Supermax facility in
Romulus and the maximum security prison
that's in Elmira we have grown from a
staff of two to a staff of eight now
each semester we teach 25 to 30 classes
involving a similar number of faculty
postdocs and graduate students who serve
as instructors and teach about a hundred
and seventy-five incarcerated students
we've had graduations now at Auburn
Hyuga and Five Points correctional
facilities for a total of about 75
graduates now one of the things that's
really unique about Cornell Prison
education program is the fact that we
have direct involvement of Cornell
undergraduates in our classrooms each
semester we utilize about 50
undergraduates as teaching assistants in
our courses and in our tutorial sessions
in addition we run a reflections course
where these undergrads get the
opportunity to talk about their
experiences teaching in prison among
their peers and with education and
prison professionals as you will see in
just a minute this is an absolutely
remarkable experience for these students
that has impacted their lives long after
they left Cornell I really want to
emphasize this is something that is not
done in any other prison education
program with maybe two exceptions it
really is something that's unique to
Cornell okay
so now that you've seen a little bit of
introduction to the prison education
program one of the questions you should
be asking us so what it's really like to
teach in a prison
so I'll give you a few things that are
relevant the classes are two and a half
hours to three hours long one day a week
15 weeks in the semester there are no
computers or any electronics allowed in
the prison classrooms we have pencils
paper chalk blackboards and of course
our brains all class content and
material needs to be pre-approved by the
Department of Corrections there is a
strict dress code in most of the prisons
the way I'm dressed today you guys never
see me dressed this way on campus to
teach classes this is the way we have to
dress for si pepper you need to pass
through a security screening every time
you go in everything that you bring in
is going to be is going to be
scrutinized if you're lucky the
screening takes five minutes if you're
not lucky it takes an hour there's no
contact between faculty and students
outside the classroom no email no office
hours we do now have weekly tutorial
sessions which our teaching assistants
give the students assistants the
students do not have access to a
research library or any access to the
Internet and it's a 30 to 50 minute
drive each way to these prisons when the
weather is good so you're probably
asking yourself why the hell would
anybody ever want to teach in a prison
it seems like there's a lot of things
that would be negative about it and the
honest answer is for anybody who really
cares about teaching the costs don't
even come close to the benefits although
our C prep students do not have the
educational experience and background of
our Cornell students many are every bit
as capable as our Cornell students in
their ability to learn and think see
peps students are highly respectful of
their instructors and grateful for the
opportunity to take classes there is no
feeling of entitlement among our ear
CPAP students students are actually
anxious to participate in class
discussions
and to answer questions it is a
fantastic environment if you want to
practice or learn about techniques of
active learning in the classroom when
you give these students their homework
assignments they make a real effort to
do the work at the best of their ability
they really think about the material you
ask them to look at and from a lot of
experience at both ends of this I can
tell you that a two and a half hour
class in CPAP goes by much faster than a
50 minute lecture at Cornell perhaps the
discussions that happen in the car on
the way home from teaching with between
instructors and TAS may be the best
indicator on the way home everyone is so
jazzed up by their experience you can't
help but talk about it we're talking
each over each other all the time about
all the cool things that happen to us
but 20 minutes later everyone but the
driver is asleep in the car because
you're so worn out from your classroom
experience okay how are we doing here
good what I would like to do now is show
you two videos that are available on the
cpap website so if you want to go back
and look at them you can but these are
really illustrating two things the first
is a video about Cornell undergraduates
who talk about their experiences being
teaching assistants in our prison
courses and the second is a video where
a group of our graduating cpap students
reflect on their experiences so let's
see if I can make this work
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and start learning about prisons just
through a personal experience I have a
number of relatives who have been
incarcerated and it wasn't until I was a
junior in high school I began to think
about it more critically and I actually
came to Cornell wanting to do the
Cornell for education program as a
nation face it disproportionately
affects poor people and people of color
and it has just a multitude of
disastrous effects I'm planning on going
into medicine which is a field where
people get lots of second chances many
of the people at Auburn didn't have real
first chances so I see the work that I'm
doing here as contributing a small part
to giving people the chances that they
deserve the first day I taught it over
and one guy sits down and goes I'm gonna
get an a-plus in this class friend
sitting across the table from him says
no I'm gonna work hard and get the
a-plus and they go back and forth for
five minutes about who's gonna be the
better student it was a nice entree into
the program I'm president writer's block
which is an on-campus student club for
it's a student publication group and we
put together writings and artworks by
prisoners at Auburn and Cornell students
last semester we received a poem there's
a love poem about the first time he met
his wife it's actually become my
favorite poem that I've ever read I knew
the program existed before I came to
Cornell and I wanted to be part of it
before I even got admitted to the school
most of our guys are gonna be released
and they want to make a difference in
their lifestyles once their
reintegrating back into society that's
really nice to be a part of finding
their humanity is what I joined this
program for and that's what I've been
receiving I think society has forgotten
that they're human yeah they did
something in the past that they got them
here but they're still human beings and
friendly to they're constantly asking
very deep questions some of them are
more engaged than Cornell students here
I took professor Katz ensigns prison's
course and I actually took it online
over the summer and we watched the last
graduation and that was a film that
really
spoke to me a lot and so when she
mentioned that Cornell had a prison
education program that was something
that I just really based off of what I
saw in the last graduation wanted to get
involved in yeah in a class with people
who don't have lots of the resources and
opportunities that I have on a daily
basis but they are absolutely committed
to what they're learning in our earlier
classes we asked them and why they
wanted to get their degree just hearing
all the different inspirations that
really drove them to try some that's
really difficult in a prison environment
you would hear the same sentiments
echoed here on campus and it just makes
you realize that education it means the
same thing a lot of people the majority
of our students haven't had a quality
education they're the manifestations of
the disadvantages that come with it
I'm very privileged to be here and I
recognize that I want more people to
have that access to the valuable
education that I receive an important
part of the work that we do is bringing
people into a classroom where if nothing
else their minds can be liberated and
they're able to think about whatever
they want to think about and talk about
it with a level of autonomy
the classroom that's only one component
of an education the other component is
the engaged learning is how you make
what you learn on paper meaningful no
matter how much I read about people in a
book to know Mike or to know just right
I know them personally and so when I go
and I'm fighting for these issues
there's a person behind that fight I
went into it with the mindset of like
helping them slash it's like
volunteering and teaching and they would
teach me their perspective on life their
perspective on math physics and over
time I realized that I was becoming a
more mature person learning how to
approach different populations there's a
synergy there it really becomes a rich
full experience it's similar to the work
that one can do for a lifetime prior to
participating in CPAP I was aware of
mass incarceration but it's now
something that I absolutely see to be
central to the work that I do for the
rest of my life it's really gratifying
it's been a very spiritual experience
and regards to forgiveness for students
who have not done see prep and who are
interested I absolutely encourage you to
do it you will gain so much you will
learn so much and you will walk out of
it different than the way that you came
came in I think this is one of the most
meaningful things I've ever done a
Cornell I've told many of my friends and
peers about it and encouraged them to
volunteer I think that this program
makes Cornell as a whole a better place
and really makes the world a better
place
[Music]
okay this one is about 2014 graduation I
didn't expect when I came to prison to
be experienced a moment like this I mean
it's not every day you get a chance to
be with the friends and family and share
a positive moment I'm supposed to be
here and my sister my daughter my
grandson when they come here I hope that
my family will see a change man this
change right here marks the most
important change in my life this means
evolution he has a human being I've
evolved I was giving you the tools that
I need to think things through rather
than just react to things I mean most of
us end up here because of that we don't
think things out we just react
emotionally the environment feeds that
once you get here but CPAP is has helped
change that there's a real magic to
these classes you're shaping the way the
class is taught and they become
something more than just a class I don't
have a specific favorite I enjoyed a lot
of classes English I love writing I
would have to say meditation the
instructor to really helpful I really
appreciated that
the things that I've learned I'm able to
really practice I'm involved in a youth
leadership organization right here in
the facility we teach Civic
consciousness community service your
duty as a citizen this program has
allowed me to move forward our sentence
to life so I want to live my daughters
coming here to witness this graduation
today God willing with the snow that she
makes it through I know he's worked so
hard and he's written so many things
about me and my brother and he does it
for us I'm very happy to see you here
graduating
this year student address will be given
by Leroy Taylor Cornell prison education
program is not only about education it's
about bringing people together a lot of
times we get jet Fuli on paper they see
you know your crime and that's all the
comments that I get back at the end of
class that lets me know that they see me
for who I really am as opposed to you
know what's being said I cannot tell you
how very proud I am of each and every
one of you you've done just one heck of
a job please welcome to the stage this
year's valedictorian
Nathan Powell short term gain was never
the goal of liberal arts the goal is to
learn as much as possible especially how
to think so you can give back to and
enrich your community the rest of the
world had us tagged and bagged and you
came in here and you cared and we will
pass your gift on
[Music]
[Applause]
I just wanna show them that I tried to
make it right I messed up but I just
want to get back my way of saying thank
you we have a responsibility to be a
beacon to all those lost in the darkness
to burn away the gloom of ignorance and
provide a clear path to a stronger
society one where no one spark is left
to fade and where Noah's promise is left
unfulfilled thank you okay so just to
finish up I'm sorry when I watch that
video I've seen it a hundred times and
eight or nine of those guys in their
graduating class I had in at least one
class one of them I had in three biology
classes he just kept taking introductory
biology classes because he was so
interested in learning but I can't help
but get choked up when I watched that
you just it's it's hard to explain well
it's not hard to explain faculty here
you know you get attached to your
students ain't you getting you develop
relationships with them it's the same
thing here and one thing I want to say I
think it's important to recognize before
I finish up is that it's important not
to view this cadre of students that I'm
talking about as being completely
representative of the entire prison
population there are some bad people in
prison but there's also people in prison
some of whom who've done bad things one
of the guys one of my favorite students
was in for a quadruple murder you know
and he was really trying to change turn
his life around he's gonna be in jail
for the rest of his life but he wanted
to get this degree so he get he set an
example for his kids so he could set an
example for his peers so that they saw
that there was something beyond
living inside those walls and being a
part of that is really something that's
worthwhile so let me thank the co
instructors and teaching assistants I've
worked with over the years and while
you're looking at that I'll just give
you a few little statistics about the
program since its founding in 1910 1910
2010 cpap has taught a total of 435
courses using 295 faculty postdocs and
graduate student instructors have taught
a total of almost 700 students in these
four central New York prisoners we've
had graduations at Auburn Cuba and five
points and really noteworthy for us last
summer we had ten students at five
points who completed our newly
accredited Cornell certificate in the
liberal arts an actual certificate from
god scott Cornell's stamp on it
president's signature on it each of
these students completed independent
research thesis is the capstone for that
program it's a real step forward in the
type of education that we're providing
these guys and of course we couldn't
have done this without donations and
funding from a lot of organizations
sunshine lady got us started but we now
have what we hope will be a permanent
support from the mellon foundation we
get a ton of support from Cornell
continuing education they waive a
million dollars worth of tuition each
year for our students so it's a big a
big help to us doing this so thanks for
your attention and I'd be glad to answer
questions
I think it is truly emotionally for me
to watch it and so I encourage you all
you know I don't know more much more
about venue to participate in questions
did you speak for a moment about the
recidivism rate yeah general program but
yeah so in New York State over the last
ten years for the state prisons the
recidivism rate is around sixty seven
percent if you look at the recidivism
rate from prison education programs
around the country that number is closer
to ten percent okay so one thing you
should keep in mind in New York State we
spend almost seventy thousand dollars a
year to keep a person in prison if we
can keep them from coming back in prison
through prison education programs and
things like that we save a lot of money
that we could do for other we could use
for other things
so when governor como introduced the
idea of rien reinstating support for
prison education in New York and there
was an outcry from people who said I
can't afford to send my son or daughter
to college because it's so expensive we
should be thinking about the amount of
money we'd be saving in New York State
if we weren't incarcerated all these
people so the the the the statistics are
really strong in terms of the affected
prison education has on the recidivism
rate that's a good point so we have had
five five graduates in the last couple
years that have gone on to degree
programs at other universities to have
come to Cornell exit and I'm sorry six
three have come to Cornell one has gone
to Stanford one has gone to Columbia and
one has gone to John Jay in New York so
we really do have very capable students
who are coming out of
out of this undergraduates yeah yes so
the question is to the undergraduates
who are who are functioning as teaching
assistants get some training yes I would
I'm it's probably true to say that a lot
of the training is directly related to
what you're gonna encounter when you go
to a prison because it's pretty
different but we also give them training
associated with teaching so part of its
sort of on-the-job training you learn
while you're there part of it comes to
the reflections course that we have but
part of it comes from training that we
gave you before you go in there as well
no no we that's not part of the training
that the that the students get before
they go in I think that that sort of
leads into an important point about the
prison education program almost everyone
who's involved in the prison education
program is an advocate of prison reform
a prison reform is not something that
see pep advocates for C pep advocates
for prison education if we spent time
advocating for for prison reform they
would throw us out of the prisons just
like that all right we have to be very
careful about the things that we do when
we're in prison we're there to teach or
not there to be critical of the system
in fact when we're out when I'm a
teacher in CPAP if I went out to a
prison prison reform rally that could
end my in my involvement with CPAP like
that so you had another part of the
question can I justify it oh man like I
said there's there people in prison who
did really bad things you know they
probably deserve to be there but because
of the war on drugs and get tough on
crime between in the 90s and the early
2000 we put
a lot of people in prison for 30 years
for three possessions of marijuana so
I'll leave that up to all of you to
decide whether that's appropriate or not
so in case you don't know this is my
wife Deborah who's also involved in CPAP
is also deeply involved in teaching and
who keeps me on track all the time yeah
so a big part of what's going on here is
a lot of these guys have kids outside of
prison and you know being in prison is
not a very good example for a parent but
them getting involved in prison
education getting their degrees we bring
their families in so they can see them
get their degrees this is really
inspiring for the kids it makes a huge
difference compared to if they just saw
their dad you know once every couple of
years in visitations in prison so it
makes a big difference as far as their
family's concerned both while they're in
prison and of course when they get out
as well rein you all out of gas yeah
what kind of what kind of things do we
want to see CPAP doing next so this new
certificate program that we have where
it's so sort of like an honors program
where the students actually do a
research thesis it's a little hard to do
a research thesis without a library in
the internet but we make it work that
sort of thing what we really want to do
is give the students as close an
experience in prison as to what they
would get us they were in classroom
outside and that means you know
encouraging them to think about stuff
outside the box giving them resources to
to expand their horizons and things that
they're interested in the independent
study programs that we give are really
good but talking to this audience we
always need people to teach science
courses we got lots of people from
government in in English and places down
on the art squad but we're short on
people to teach sciences so anybody
who's interested come talk to me and
we'll get you involved
what is the selection procedure for the
prisoners are there many more prisoners
who would like to yes yes so that
there's two main selection components
one is based on behavior so if you have
received what they call a ticket
basically you've sworn a corrections
officer you got in a fight or you were
in the wrong place at the wrong time you
can't be involved in the prison
education program the other thing is we
have an entrance exam and the entrance
exam covers both writing ability and
mathematical thinking ability because we
want to make sure that our students are
going to be capable of handling we don't
want to put them in an environment where
they're where they won't be successful
so that's those are the main criteria
that we have and yes we have many more
students who want to get into the
program than we yes they have to have a
GED or a high school high school diploma
okay I think class is going to cut us
off here this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu